- You look so beautiful!
- Oh my god you sounded so beautiful.
How amazing was that?
(audience cheering)
- Well, I was nervous
'cause you're here (laughs).
- Oh please.
- But I was like, oh it might be cool,
they requested it and yeah we
knew you were gonna be here.
- I've always loved your voice.
- Oh my gosh ditto!
- She can blow.
I love it
- Dude but singing your songs.
I've also covered a few
of your songs on tour
like over the past 17 years or whatever
and your songs, girl, they are rangey!
(laughing)
Like I love it.
(audience cheering)
It's rare, like not everybody has
that kind of range and power.
- Well thank you, thank you.
- It's rare, yeah.
- Yeah, I over-complicate
things for myself live.
(laughs)
- Don't you hate that?
And then you get to the
tour and you're like
why couldn't I just not do the octave.
- I change it up a little bit.
- You're touring right now, right?
- I am touring and, yeah,
I hadn't toured before that
in like 10 years 'cause I was --
- Why didn't you tour
for, is it 'cause kids?
- Yes I got really scared.
I'm like how do people do this?
'Cause I'm very, like I
know kids need like routine
and structure like bedtime,
the order and like,
how are you supposed to do that
whenever you're in different time zones
like every night and
things are changing, so.
- It's so hard.
- It was (laughs).
- Yeah.
I cried when I first had River
and then we had two older kids,
I cried
- It's hard!
- Like almost every night.
I was like this is so hard.
- It's so hard.
- 'Cause you don't wanna
be an absentee mom.
- And then you're off stage
and it's like oh the bedtime stories, okay
what almost there to the, you know.
- And they're like sing me a song
and I'm like I just did.
(audience laughs)
You're welcome.
- See I have it more easy.
- You didn't have
to pay for it.
- I have it more easy 'cause
my daughter will be like
shh I'm trying to sleep.
And I'm there like okay cool.
- My daughter does that to me!
She also, she'll be like let's
sing and then she'll go shh.
- Yes she does the hand to me too!
- I'm like people pay for this.
- She gives me that hand, they don't know,
they don't know.
- Yes, they shush you.
They don't care , it's kind of awesome.
- Yeah it's great.
- 'Cause it keeps us humble
our kids don't care at all.
No I love you and I love that actually,
I feel like we have
similar childhoods speaking
about parenting and everything.
Like I have like major abandonment issues
so like that's one reason why I am like
not a helicopter mom but I really wanna
be there for everything.
- Same I do too.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- You had kind of a normal childhood
but it was kind of hard, right?
Y'all struggled a bit.
- Yeah, it was a chaotic childhood
and lots of moving.
We've moved a lot of different places.
My dad was in the army so it
was like a lot of shifting
and people ask me like where are you from?
I'm like I was born in Staten Island
but I was raised everywhere, like Japan,
like everything, so--
- Japan?
- Yeah, Japan for three years.
- What?
- Yeah, so I just--
- I love Japan.
- It's, isn't it fun?
- It is so fun.
Tokyo, so many things.
- It's so beautiful.
- So many things, yeah.
- Yeah!
Oh my gosh
that's so exciting!
- I keep forgetting
to post pictures from it
but yeah, it was amazing.
- Here's it, I know I like your life!
- I'm not a poster everybody was wow.
- I'm not either 'cause
don't you feel like vain?
Don't you feel it?
- I do!
- Yeah I think so many egocentric!
- Well 'cause social media was not around
when I was--
- I'm so thankful!
I'm so thankful!
- Now it's kinda frightening
to think of where it's gonna be
when our kids are like--
- Yeah, I'm not even like
giving them phones.
(audience laughs)
I'm like send a pigeon.
- But yes, I did feel it at first.
I was like what is this selfie,
like why do I want that in my face?
Like ah!
- I know!
- Like you know what I mean?
- Yeah I feel like it's
like vanity run amuck,
but I know people get
into it, yeah I know.
But one of the reasons why I loved,
and I have covered a lot of your songs,
honestly is because, for females,
you have such an amazing catalog,
like your empowerment level
of females especially,
it's so cool!
- Thank you.
- Yeah and I know,
I've just heard you speak
a little in interviews
here and there just 'cause of a fan,
and we both have a little bit
of an emotional upbringing
as well as financial,
and I think that's why it's so powerful,
when you sing those anthems--
- Thank you
- Because you're so believable.
- I appreciate that.
- I love your anthems.
- Authenticity is very
important to me with my music.
It's probably why I take so long to,
I can't just take a song and do it,
that's like regurgitating, not your truth.
And I made a decision when
I made the Stripped album,
which was my follow up to my first--
- Which was real good. I saw
that tour, it was so good!
In Dallas, in Dallas, I was like "Yes!"
- With the chaps and the--
- It was so good!
You say Eda James, and I was like yes!
(audience laughs)
Yes, it was so good.
- And what were we even talking about?
- I don't even know.
(couple laughs)
I was bragging about you,
'cause you know, you
give me chills and I--
- And the truth, I've always
wanted to be a truth seeker,
and I felt like that was really
important to my fans too,
after Stripped, I really told my truth,
and, you know, sides to
all woman that we are.
You know, we shouldn't
be apologetic if we have,
for our sexual side,
for our vulnerable side,
through being a fighter
and overcoming obstacles.
And I think those are all messages
that were really important to me.
- That we're all different.
(audience laughs)
That's what I love about the industry too,
is like even though we're all different,
there's room for everyone.
There's room for everyone at the table.
- Always, always.
- And that's what I love about you too,
you actually say, I know Demi's a big fan,
and y'all did that song together.
- Yes!
- I love that.
It was really really cool.
But I have a question.
So, when I'm on tour, I know that,
there's always like one
song that I'm still like
so excited about.
Like I'm, funny enough, it's actually,
I had no idea, no one told
me at RCA, on my first label,
this is true, I got my record
and I was like oh my god,
my first record, and I'm like
sitting here looking at the booklet,
and I was like, why is
Christina Aguilera in it,
and I was like what?
And so you wrote, I didn't
know you wrote with Red,
the beginning of 'Miss Independent',
like that part of that,
I didn't know that.
- Oh that's right.
- I had no idea.
(audience cheers)
I literally, no one told me.
- I had no idea where
you were going with that.
I was like, oh okay.
- No!
No because honestly no one told me
and I think this is the
thing that pissed me off,
'cause it's like why didn't you tell me,
'cause I love her.
And I would have been so excited,
and what they told me is they were like,
well not all females love to
support all other females.
And I was like, well
let's get rid of them.
- That's messed up.
- Yeah, I--
- That's one of the
most discouraging things
I think about this business is
people definitely categorize
and pit you against each other,
when you have like even no idea.
- Why don't they do that with males?
- So stupid.
- I know.
(audience laughs)
- We're changing it, we're changing it.
- We're changing it!
(audience cheers)
Is there a song that
you still love though,
like on your, like when you go on tour,
you're like oh my god I
can't wait to sing this.
- Energetically what's super fun is
when the beginning opening
of 'Dirty' comes on.
- I was hoping you would say 'Dirty'.
I love that video.
- And then, thank you,
and then the vulnerability
and the connection
that 'Beautiful' has with
people when I sing it,
it's such a relatable song
and such a truthful one too,
you know, just expressing your
insecurities and being like,
well that's what I am,
and accepting yourself for it.
- Well and we all
have insecurities, and we all have,
it's funny, 'cause that's
why I wanted to do this show,
is that we all have far more commonalities
than differences,
and that's one thing that I feel like
we should focus more on
because everybody is so divided
right now and I don't understand,
but anyway I have a couple a songs,
that if you want me to I'll mention,
I hate singing them on tour,
but what is one that you're like (groans)
like every time you get
on stage you're like,
"Good I get to do it again."
(audience laughs)
Do you want me to go first
and make you feel better?
- Sure.
- Okay, I don't know if you're
gonna feel bad about it.
- Don't say 'Miss Independent.' (laughs)
- No my band, my band is here,
like that's been with me forever.
Is 'Miss Independent' not my favorite?
I'm not kidding, it's
like super rocked out,
the version we do on tour,
and it's my favorite.
And it was my first single, so funny.
But no the one, I think
because it wasn't for me,
do not hate me, do not
boo me, I will slap you.
I won't slap you 'cause I
don't want you to sue me,
but (laughs), but it's,
'A Moment Like This' and only because,
don't you gasp!
But only because it wasn't written for me,
it was written for the winner.
And so it could have been anybody's,
and so I feel like it wasn't,
like special for me.
- Okay,
that's fair enough.
- What's yours?
- Can I just say I really
love your set-up by the way.
- Oh thank you.
- So comfy.
I wish every talk show
had a set-up like this.
- I did make sure, because of my height,
like we're both short,
I wanted pillows behind
people because I was--
- I know I love it!
- I'm like this.
- Me too!
- Yeah.
- It's not fair!
- It's not fun being short.
- I feel like we're just
girlfriends gabbing right now.
I don't even know if anybody's here.
(laughs)
What do I not like to sing...
'Hurt', 'Hurt' is a big one.
- 'Cause that's a big vocal.
- And it's all like all
(Christina sings)
Like it's all extended vocals.
- Yep.
- So it's really--
- But you do some really great
head voice things,
your head voice is like legit my fave.
- You're so sweet.
- It's so pretty.
I'm just gonna brag on you some more.